te crees todo lo que sale en medios de
comunicación
según el estudio reciente el 63 66 3%
las noticias son falsas directamente
falsas y un 40% uno de cada diez cuatro
de cada diez periodistas confiesa haber
publicado al menos una noticia falsa en
el último año
y bueno un 34% de los asistentes
os habéis creído de esta noticia que
por cierto
me la ha inventado
estamos en una nueva era y al empezar el
siglo siendo muy optimistas la llamamos
la era de la información y sí es cierto
que nunca ha sido tan fácil transmitir
conocimiento pero hay una cara oculta
que ha tardado más en manifestarse y es
que en gran medida vivimos en la era de
la información la era de los bulos el
clic para los fake news una era en la
que importa más el interés que algo
despierta que su veracidad
en consecuencia sucesos que son
noticiables
y tienen más importancia que la razón o
el sentido común
minoves time a karting he estudiado he
explotado y explicado este fenómeno
durante años y he convertido mi análisis
en una ciencia la ciencia de crear
noticia habilidad
sobre esta ciencia ha escrito un libro
he creado empresas impartido en muchas
formaciones
pero antes de explicarla os quiero
avisar
y algunos os vais a ofender por lo que
voy a decir
otros lo entenderéis como una crítica a
la sociedad y otros los más vivos lo
veréis como una oportunidad para sacar
provecho
pero no discutáis porque todos estáis en
lo cierto
un ejemplo las lecciones del año 2016 en
eeuu irán a mucho esfuerzo en pulso por
sorpresa donald trump ganó contra todo
pronóstico
pero lo que mucha gente no sabe es que
trump tenía uno de los presupuestos en
marketing más bajos
es decir invirtió
hasta ocho veces menos en marketing que
el primer candidato
no pagaba porque la gente hablase de él
solamente 10 millones que suena como
mucho dinero pero son son céntimos para
ellos
sin embargo las apariciones que tuvo en
medios
fueron brutales o sea como podéis ver la
gráfica casi se sale de lo que
consiguieron sus competidores como jet
box que es el que más invirtió
y los números por qué
son números que cuesta decir pero se ha
consiguió publicidad gratuita valorarán
mil 898 millones de dólares solo pagando
si eres como yo te preguntas
cómo
como lo hizo que que es cuál es esta
estrategia
para entender cómo hizo suelo explicar
esta herramienta lo llamo en inglés el
news work canvas
está bien se ha ido así como el lienzo
de noticiabilidad este lienzo es una
herramienta que sirve para entender por
qué algo es noticia pero también sirve
para crear noticias
es decir [ __ ] algo que no es noticia y
convertirlo en noticia
el lienzo tiene siete módulos
y son un módulo por cada uno de los
siete criterios de noticiabilidad estos
siete criterios no me los he inventado
yo esto es algo que se estudia en
universidades de periodismo de todo el
mundo para que los periodistas decidan
qué es noticia y qué no
y en definitiva es una herramienta es
una herramienta para hacer que algo sea
noticiable
acabamos es noticiable tiene que ser en
primer lugar actual
no pudo suceder hace una semana o dentro
de una semana
tiene que suceder ahora mismo si no es
inmediato no es noticia
tiene que ser cercano cercano al medio
cercano a casa para que se considere que
es noticia si quieres salir en la voz de
granada
tienes que estar sucediendo en granada
así que salir en un medio nacional como
la sexta tiene estar afectando a todo el
país
tiene que haber conflicto el drama no
amigos y enemigos una pelea
si no hay conflicto no es noticia
inesperado
inesperado bizarro como nieve en agosto
o como un atentado terrorista
impacto social
esto significa que afecte a muchas
personas a poder ser el cien por cien de
la población a la que se dirige el medio
por ejemplo una subida en el iva una
subida del iva no es nada mágico pero
nos afecta a todos así que es noticia
una ola de calor es similar nos afecta a
todos así que las noticias
y si involucra a personas relevantes va
a ser noticia estas personas pueden ser
individuos o instituciones pues es la
onu o puede ser
belén esteban y su boda
tiene que ser personas relevantes para
que algo sea noticia
y estos son un poco los criterios y
podría dar muchos ejemplos de como trump
una y otra vez utiliza
estos criterios para inventarse cosas
noticiables sacarse ases de la manga voy
a dar mi ejemplos pero me gusta este
porque es muy fácil de entender
no sé si sabía esperó en un mitin
electoral en mitad de la campaña se le
ocurrió que era buena idea
imitar a un discapacitado un periodista
discapacitado que escribió sobre él y le
imitó
pensarás porque haría alguien algo así
porque es noticia
inmediatamente es noticia gratis y hace
que salgan medios de comunicación por lo
que podemos ver su campaña sin que paga
por ella y podemos ver los banners no
los los cartelitos de sus la gente que
la apoya vamos a analizar esto desde la
perspectiva de del lienzo de
noticiabilidad como podéis ver tiene
conflicto en cuanto a que es un hombre
poderoso contra un inusual y a una
persona discapacitada él es inesperado
no hay que explicar por qué pero bueno
no digamos que no espera a ser un adulto
imitando a otro adulto tal vez en un
patio del colegio
luego es tiene tiene impacto social nos
afecta a todos son eeuu primero que es
un tema sensible a nadie le gusta que se
metan con una persona desvalida
pero también tener en cuenta que esta
persona es una persona que tiene acceso
al botón nuclear de eeuu así que nos
afecta a todos y este es uno de muchos
sucesos porque las historias noticiables
de trump son de todos los tamaños y
todos los colores pero tienen algo en
común todos le consiguen publicidad
gratis y es lo que consigue que en
efecto ganase las elecciones se
convirtieran presidente gastando tan
poquito en marketing
esto no ha sucedido solamente en eeuu ha
sucedido recientemente con líderes
políticos en países como brasil y méjico
aquí podríamos hablar de box aunque por
suerte no termino tragedia
pero yo quiero preguntarme no esos
efectos políticos pero cuáles son los
efectos económicos aspectos
empresariales digamos me gusta el caso
de google
el mundo sabe que es su ver hoy en día
en 2014 cuando entraron a españa muy
poca gente sabía lo que era über en
españa
porque no era noticia nadie hablaba de
ello porque este es un lienzo de
noticiabilidad no es nada cercano es una
empresa americana no no no impacta no
nos impactaba y no no era realmente
inesperado no había nada bizarro con
ello por lo tanto no era noticia
no hablábamos de ello hasta que un día
sucedió esto
hubo unos recordáis la huelga de
taxistas en contra über en barcelona el
esto es un suceso muy noticiable que
über no tuvo que fabricar como trasvase
sin embargo les vaya muy bien pasó de
ser un desconocido en nuestro país a
estar en el número 3 de descargas en el
apple store en todo el país y sólo
empezó a operar en barcelona seguirá
había gente en albacete bajándose la app
de huber
por qué
tenía muchos criterios de noticiabilidad
una presa extranjera que no es cercana a
casa de repente era cercana a casa
porque la huelga sucede en casa no
impacte a muchas personas porque las
huelgas tienen impacto social pero
además había un gran componente de
empleos en riesgo nos vamos a quedar sin
trabajo porque esto suceda lo verá
inesperado sobre todo porque hubo dos
heridos
claro muchísimo conflicto una huelga y
las fotos veías el drama podías
entrevistar al taxista podías
entrevistar a alguien de uber y así es
como sucedió que huber subir al top 3 de
descargas y esto no es un hecho aislado
a principios de 2019 otra huelga en
madrid contra über y cuddy fine y lo
mismo las descargas y los usos de uber y
califa en esa semana fueron el doble de
altos que la semana anterior
la noticiabilidad funciona
aquello de que hablen de aquí aunque sea
malo funciona ven en mi libro el fondo
también casos pues bueno además de uber
y trump habló de hilo en más con tesla
habló de red bull la bebida de la que
nadie voy a hablar hasta que se supone
que causaba infartos pero buenos quiero
dar un caso un poco más cercano a casa
un caso de una empresa española y es el
caso de vic life
y live la idea detrás de esta empresa es
es muy sencilla y casi demasiado
sencillas un vino de color azul
esta empresa se creó hace
aproximadamente cinco años por cinco
jóvenes emprendedores yo entre ellos y a
día de hoy hemos vendido cuatro millones
de botellas sin un euro de inversión
sin duda os puedo confesar y admitir que
el éxito ha sido exclusivamente las
apariciones en medios es millones de
euros en publicidad gratis
como por qué
y pues igual que donald trump igual que
über igual que noticiabilidad
el vino azul no era la historia de un
mira azul era un suceso noticiable
primero tenía conflicto porque esta
historia de cómo la industria
tradicional vinícola trataba de aplastar
a unos jóvenes innovadores si tenía
mucho conflicto
por otro lado nos venía muy cerca la
casa muy cercano a españa y todos los
países que fueran muy vinícolas porque
el vino es algo muy nuestro es la sangre
de cristo hay un gran componente de
tradición así que vengan unos chavales a
cambiar la sangre de cristo tienes este
impacto social evidentemente es muy
inesperado no es que fuera azul así que
es inesperado es tenemos que hacer lo
inesperado así que hagámoslo azul
y bueno es el vino más instagram el
hable del mundo no hay más que decirlo
era muy local porque trabajamos con
distintas bodegas de españa así que
podíamos salir en un medio de aragón por
la bodega de aragón uno de cataluña por
cataluña
y así funciona el juego hoy en día esa
es la era en la que vivimos
todo este conjunto de información de
conocimiento lo llamo las dinámicas de
noticiabilidad nurse words dinamics y la
realidad que la gente que entiende las
dinámicas de noticiabilidad llevan
ventaja a aquellos que no las entienden
porque van a ser capaces de despertar el
interés de las masas y lanzar proyectos
sin romperse el bolsillo con un
presupuesto en marketing
y por eso estoy hoy aquí
no para hablar de mi libro sino para que
vosotros entendáis las dinámicas de
noticiabilidad y os convirtáis de alguna
manera en gente menos manipulable
inmunizarlos contra la desinformación
cuando leáis algo os preguntéis qué
elementos se han metido aquí con
calzador para que yo quiera hablar de
ello o leer sobre ello al mismo tiempo
por qué no tomar este poder el poder de
la viralidad el poder de la
noticiabilidad y usarlo donde más se
necesita
proyectos de carácter social
innovaciones hechas por equipos que no
tienen el apoyo de grandes empresas pero
tiene que competir contra ellas
y eso es en lo que yo creo creo que es
posible y creo que es hora de
inmunizarnos contra la desinformación
ahora es vuestro turno
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]